hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of the 2021 candidates
tournament in yekaterinbury
russia uh it's iannipolis versus maxime
bashar lagrave and
as you probably remember from the
previous video of the candidates these
are the standings after round 12 so that
nipple is leading with eight points
uh and anish is following with seven and
a half which means
uh if nipple wins this one he's gonna be
on nine points
uh then anish would have to win to be on
eight and a half points and then he
would have
like amazing chances in the in in the
final round to win this but if he wins
and the geary does not win
then it is all over then uh uh nepo
is the challenger of magnus carlsen uh
in the next wheelchair championship
match
so without further ado let's check it
out as it is quite the game so here
nipple with the white pieces opens with
the knight to f3
uh we have knight to f6 c4 and b6
now uh the english opening but going for
kind of a queens indian setup
uh we have g3 uh bishop to b7 and the
bishop to g2 and now
g6 maximum will now fianchetto the dark
square bishop as well
and he's trying some sort of an offbeat
opening idea
uh maybe to to well not exchange
anything too quickly
uh in the opening and you know the
longer
the longer the game goes on uh maybe he
can create some chances
to grab a full point here because maxime
here i don't
know if you guys were paying attention
to that but maxine isn't currently in
third place and if he wins
both of his next games he's also a
contender for the world champs
championship match
so here we have uh g6 like we said uh d4
and now bishop to g7 fiance doing the
dark square bishop as well
and now castles is the uh most often
move
that is played here but here we have
just the d5 grabbing more space in the
center preventing black from
executing d5 and now knight to a6
very interesting here would be a b5 it's
kind of wasting the tempo because you
already played b6 but it is very
interesting
uh you're just trying to weaken the the
d5 pawn
trying to claim that okay with d5 now
you overextend
i'm just going to undermine your pawn
chain and then we might see something
like
queen b3 going after the pawn and then
c6
if knight to c3 we can just trade here
captures captures
and we have this position where it's uh
it's better for white but
i i guess it's always better for white
if you play such a such an opening with
black but that's kind of the idea
uh trying to suffer for you know uh a
small part of the opening
segment and then you know look for your
chances later on
uh but okay after the five we have
knight to a6 by maxine not going for
anything too crazy knight to c3
and now knight to c5 now this is an
excellent square for the knight
and you can't really kick it away right
away now b4 although very interesting
you would simply this would be met with
knight after e4 and then there's a
double attack on the knight here if you
move the knight then the rook falls
uh so b4 for the moment not possible so
here just
castles uh we have castles by maxine and
the queen to c2 now
nicely developed developing with a5 uh
and now there are a few games in the
database or rather i think there's just
one where e4 was played but here we have
rook to d1 and
it is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
maxime deals with this
actually he he shifts the knight back
knight to e8 and now
of course he will have to start
advancing those pawns in the center at
some point
uh d6 e5 f5 and so on if he wants to
create some chances so here
f a bishop to f4 controlling the e5
square and now
knight to d6 and this is now a beautiful
piece here
uh at some point white can grab it to
create some chances here maybe to double
up black's pawn structure
uh but obviously if maxim is playing
this without spending pretty much any
time
you know he came prepared with this so
here b3 and the situation on the clock
is nipple some
hour and 25 minutes whereas the maxim is
a bit lower i think an hour and
15 or 17 minutes uh here we have rook to
e8 again
ready to strike in the center with e5
but now uh
bishop the e5 another idea is maybe just
knight to d4 uh
which kind of prevents e5 because if you
go e5
now then d captures an e6 alpha song the
captures and
knight d to b5 and it's uh it's uh well
it's a very fun position
there's a triple attack on this knight
here and if you defend it or
you could just trade first captures
captures and then defend the knight seat
to b7
uh you get the disposition and then for
example you trade once uh captures
captures and rotate the c1
and white uh has very nice development
and you know very harmonious development
to the pieces
and should be doing all right uh but
instead of knight to d4 nipple prefers
bishop to e5 he wants to get the dark
square bishops off the board
and now you could capture here and then
play e6 uh but
maxine decides uh if a capture is to
occur it's uh best that it occurs
on g7 so here e6 right away and
now bishop captures uh on ng
seven uh we have uh king captures and
now
rook a to b one uh nipple here wants to
play rook eight to b1 a3 and b4
uh although uh a3 and b4 might be an
idea even with
with the rook on a1 but of course he
knows what he is doing so rook 8 to b1
and now e5 grabbing more space in the
center and now you are already looking
at some point pushes with f5
e4 f4 if uh if white allows it
and now e4 uh could be an idea here but
yam prefers knight to d2 so for the
moment over protecting this uh e4 square
uh with both knights the queen and the
bishop but also keeping an eye here on
the queen side a3 and b4 are coming
so here we have f5 by maxime and now
comes a3 preparing b4
and now maxim has to decide does he want
to play a slow move does he want to play
a developing move like maybe queen to c6
or should he push in the center e4
f4 so we're going to discuss e4 and f4 a
little bit
because those are the moves that
immediately come to mind uh if you try
something like e4 it looks very nice
but white just continues with b4 and uh
for example captures captures knight has
to go back now we're going to play e3
and it's not well it's not much to look
at you've weakened the d4 square now
white can shift
the knight over to d4 if uh if white
wishes so and there's not much black can
do to help out
with the development of uh his pieces so
e4
maybe not the the greatest idea f4 on
the other hand
is a bit more dangerous but uh we're
still gonna go b4 captures capture snide
a6
and now knight to b5 and this is a
pretty wild idea
uh because if you capture it knight
captures here then c captures on b5
and what do you do with this knight here
there's really not all that much you can
do you have to move it back
and then even d6 now opening up a
discovery on the bishop
and uh with a double attack on the c6
square so you have to play c6 blocking
this
and now rook to a1 you will trade off
your rooks captures captures and black's
position is just
a disgusting this is this will be
impossible to hold
if you try something like queen a6 just
rook to a7 and that's it there's really
not much you can do about this position
at at some point you're going to capture
here once this bishop probably moves to
c8 or something and
then it's just all over so what you
would have to do after knight to b5
is not capture this maybe maybe you
could go for some sort of an in-between
move f captures and g3
uh but still h captures and g3 and again
uh you you have to play something and
there really uh
doesn't seem to be a good move here like
knights to f7 or knight f5 are possible
uh but it it just looks very ugly so
these are the possibilities that uh
could occur uh sorry about that uh after
uh e4
or f4 so none of them looking too great
so maxime just continues development
queen to f6
and now nepo continues with his uh pawn
pushing on the queen side with b4
captures captures and now comes knight
to a6
and here it's interesting that uh nepo
has some one hour on the clock maximum
some 15 minutes on the clock
but the deposition is very delicate so
feel free to pause the video here and
what would you play in this position
have at it while i while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it
do what exactly because it's not like
it's a winning idea but
for those of you that found it
congratulations on you know going really
deep into the position and for those of
you who just want to enjoy
the show it's c5 c5 is a beautiful pawn
sacrifice that simply
uh gives white a better position and i
will show you why this is so because
after c5
uh we uh obviously you have to do
something
best is to just capture and then after
captures captures and captures
yes you win a pawn and you defend your
bishop here
but here comes knight to b5 now
threatening knight captures on c7
with an attack on both rooks but also
you've opened up a discovery towards the
knight on c5
and now after this knight is eliminated
we're gonna capture this knight with
a double attack on the knight here uh
you can't really
move the knight uh otherwise we're just
gonna well for example if you go knight
to d6 yes this is defended but just
queen captures and then black's entire
position falls apart
this is the thread this is a threat too
many threats
so instead after this we have c6 kind of
defending everything
but now comes the real idea d captures
on c6 we have
d captures on c6 and rook captures on b5
pawn captures and now bishop captures
and b7 and now
it all depends how black would continue
playing this uh you could go some like
rook to d8 then we just pick up the pawn
or you could try something like rook to
b8
to keep an eye on this pawn for example
bishop to d5 and then continues with
white having a bishop and the knight for
a rook
and the white's position uh will be
better here but again it's very hard to
decide whether whether black's past pawn
uh will be a problem or not for the
moment not really because you
kind of have a firm grip on the b3
square you you could probably create
some sort of a
blockade here you know using d for
square and it could all
turn out really well but this was not
played in the game
so i just uh you know wanted to
congratulate to everyone who
thought of c5 but in the game e4 was
played by nipple and now
uh maxime kind of feels uh pressured
into pushing f4 as this is what he
played
for so f4 uh end and now comes knight to
e2 now with
the idea of just capturing here because
then the queen cannot capture gonna have
to capture with the pawn
and then this diagonal will open up
giving white a lot of uh
potential here you don't have a dark
square bishop but you might be able to
uh weaken uh you're gonna weaken the d4
square you're gonna get a knight in
there and then you know that
take it from there but for the moment
your pieces are much better the knight
bishop rook
really not uh not a part of this game so
here we have f
captures on g3 and this is very nice
another idea is just c5 but
uh you know uh for example d captures d
captures and then g
captures on f4 e captures and not knight
to f3
this is the deadly idea uh point is that
you cannot capture on e4
if you capture an e4 then you get this
very nasty rook to d7 check
and now if you block this there's always
a rook captures and b7 rook captures and
queen captures an e4 again giving up the
rook for two pieces
so what you would have to do probably
after this knight to f3
is defended the e5 square but white will
still push
e5 and after captures you're going to
play captures captures and now again
this very nasty rook to d7 check
rook the e7 you're going to play
captures captures and then knight
captures on f4 so this is one
possibility the material is completely
equal and the white's position is a
little bit better his pieces are a bit
more active
but it's uh again very dangerous and
very very double edged
uh but uh it was it was definitely in
the position uh however here we have f
captures and g3 right away
f captures on g3 h captures also a
possibility kind of a
maybe a more principled idea but uh nepo
decides to go f captures on g3
that might have something to do with
maybe rook f8 creating
a target on f2 at some point in the
future who knows and only now c5 so
pretty much the same idea with the
inclusion of one captures here
so b captures on c5 and now he has to
decide what to do here the capture with
the knight or with the pawn
and capturing with the pawn seems a
pretty pretty self-explanatory as
uh well you don't want to give up upon
the problem is
if you do this then there are all sorts
of very nasty tricks in the position
like
queen to a4 and now uh the
pawn here is being uh threatened and you
don't have time to play knight to b4 the
move you've intended to play and for
example if queen e7 defending this
bishop h3 again we pile up on this pawn
we don't even have to play this we can
play queen a5 we can go after this pawn
also queen a3
so we could you know uh there are a lot
of very
very good ideas here for white so
although it seems like you're
uh saving your pawn you're maybe just uh
you know prolonging
its uh you know loss so instead after b
captures in c5 we have knight captures
on c5
giving up the pawn right away uh we have
rook captures in the now comes queen to
d8
attacking the rook pushing it back but
of course nipple just doubles up on the
b
file we have rook to cease uh queen to
c7 now
uh adding more protection to this bishop
and preparing to pile up on the c4 pawn
bishop the a6 is coming maybe
and then everything will you know join
up in uh
winning back the pawn so knight back the
c3
or rather forward and now rook to f8
uh the rook wasn't really doing all that
much on the e file so now you just shift
it to the open f file maybe you can use
it
there uh we have rook six to b2 uh you
wanna you wanna get this knight over
probably somewhere to b5 and you don't
wanna do it while the rook is here
because then just queen capture so you
have to move it back
rook to b4 also an idea maybe to add
additional protection to the c4 pawn but
okay nipple goes for
rook to b2 we have bishop to a6 and now
at knights to d1 so the c4 pawn is
sufficiently defended
that's not a problem rook ate the b8 and
here that nepo just trades everything
off he plays rook characters on b8
you could not trade for example you
could play some like queen c3 threaten
the e5 pawn because it is weak and after
let's say knight f7 defending the pawn
uh now go queen e3 and it's uh maybe a
slight improvement in uh you know
how how active your queen is but still
it doesn't really do all that much
just d6 and then black continues uh the
game normally but nepo decided to trade
everything off we have captures captures
characters captures and now queen to b2
uh
causing captures and captures and now we
have this end game
where nipple is up upon but uh you know
uh being up upon uh
usually is not uh is not enough uh to
win the game so let's see if it was
enough in this game so here in knight c8
remaneuvering the knights to add another
attacker
from b6 uh and now comes king to f2
nipple starts bringing the king into the
game
knight to b6 also you at some point want
to play d6 but maybe um you know
there is time for that we have bishop to
f1 adding another defender here and only
now
d6 we have king to e3 uh that's not e3
king to e3 and now
king to f6 we have bishop to e2
and here king to e7 and here uh although
you are
up upon it's very very hard to make any
progress here so here
uh nipple not too too eager to go crazy
because he's still leading the
tournament
and he probably saw what was happening
in the uh anish versus uh
alexander gesho game and he wasn't very
impressed by that so i guess he
he thought that there was no need of
maybe trying to push for anything here
and of course nepal can assess positions
very well so he
most likely knows that he will not be
able to convert an extra pawn here
so here at knight to b1 we've bishop to
c8 and
and now a nice repetition of moves
knight c3 bishop here
bishop d1 bishop e8 bishop to c2 and
bishop to d7 and it was in this
move on move 40 as the players reached
time control
that they agreed to a draw so yeah
really wild stuff and other than that uh
idea that we've mentioned
uh here after knight to a6 this uh pawn
sacrifice
with c5 that um kind of you know uh ends
up
with with this position you having the
bishop and knight for a rook uh
other than this there really weren't all
that many uh chances for either of them
in this game but an
interesting choice of opening for maxine
and uh
you know uh jan play played very well
against it
and it didn't work out for this game so
i guess we will still
see what happens in the other game as
what happens in the game alexander
versus anishigiri will
could have very well decided the fate of
this tournament
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
matthew benoit
brad wright tiberio and craig wall for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos
here uh what is this
oh uh
my recording software my recording
software
uh is saying start recording and i
thought it was um
i thought it was not recording which
sometimes happens to me and i thought
no i did it again uh but uh in the end
it didn't
uh yeah luckily for that uh so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it and uh i will see you in the next one
most likely a niche gear versus
alexander glisher game
uh so see you soon guys